(playful music)
- [Voiceover] This is
BammBamm. He's a Babirusa.
Yes, that is a real animal.
A member of the pig family,
this prehistoric-looking creature
is native to the small
Indonesian island of Sulawesi.
In males, the upper canine
teeth grow straight up
through the flesh of its own snout
and curve back towards their eyes.
As they get older, the tusks
can get spectacularly large,
and on rare occasions have grown so big
as to pierce their own skulls.
Babirusas spend much of
their time foraging for food,
eating everything from roots, leaves
and fruits, to meat and grubs.
His strong jaws are easily capable
of cracking the hardest of nuts.
In its native island home, the
Babirusa has no natural predators.
But overhunting and conversion of
their rainforest habitat to farmland
has reduced their wild population
to less than a few thousand.
This is the Babirusa.
(playful music)